coup d'état en guinée bissao les
militaires en rébellion depuis près d'un
an ont pris le pouvoir après 24 heures
de combats dans la capitale et évincer
le président vieira
au moins 70 victimes lors de ces
affrontements nathalie moisan d'intenses
combats ont occupé les rues de bissao
toute la journée
24 heures d'affrontements qui auront
suffit au général manea sa junte
militaire pour déposer le président
vieira
au cours des combats l'ambassade de
france a été pilonnée par les rebelles
mais les 25 personnes qui travaillaient
ont pu fuir avant que le bâtiment ne
prenne ce sains et saufs ils ont trouvé
refuge à l'ambassade du portugal
là se trouvait déjà le président tout
juste déposé vieira dont les troupes
venaient de se rendre ces affrontements
sont intervenus alors qu'un processus de
fès est engagée entre les deux anciens
amis devenus rivaux de guinée-bissau le
général manille et le président vieira
au pouvoir depuis 18 ans en février
dernier un accord entre les deux hommes
avaient mis fin à la rébellion
déclenchée en juin 98
il aura donc tenu trois mois à 59 ans le
nouvel homme fort de guinée bissao peut
se prévaloir du soutien de l'armée
son rival malheureux aurait lui demandé
l'asile politique au portugal
l'ancien pays colonisateur
[Applaudissements]